Siria ha acusado a Israel de perpetrar
un ataque con misiles contra el
aeropuerto de alepo en el Noroeste del
país en lo que supone el segundo ataque
contra estas instalaciones en los
últimos seis meses una fuente militar
Siria indicó a la agencia Estatal sana
que los proyectiles lanzados desde el
mar Mediterráneo sobre las dos de la
mañana causaron daños materiales en el
aeródromo al punto de dejarlo fuera de
servicio esto imposibilita que alepo
pueda recibir vuelos sobre todo aquellos
que estaban aterrizando con ayuda
humanitaria internacional para Los
afectados por el terremoto del 6 de
febrero Y que ahora tendrán que ser
redirigidos a Damasco o el ataque de ahí
la condena del Ministerio de exteriores
sirio que catalogó el ataque de doble
crimen por apuntaron al aeropuerto civil
y a la ruta principal de la asistencia
para una de las zonas más golpeadas por
el sismo desde Israel en tanto no hubo
comentarios en línea con la política de
no reconocer estas operaciones en Siria
cientos en los últimos años en las zonas
controladas por el régimen de vallar a
las Aliado de para Israel la presencia
de milicias apoyadas por Teherán en
Siria es una amenaza a su seguridad y
sus bombardeos en terminales aéreas o
portuarias buscan evitar la entrega de
armamento desde Irán que según el estado
hebreo lo introduciría en viajes
comerciales con el de alepo ya son
cuatro los ataques israelíes en
territorio sirio en 2023 de acuerdo al
observatorio sirio de Derechos Humanos
el anterior y más importante ocurrió el
19 de febrero en una zona Residencial de
Damasco que causó la muerte de cinco
personas y dejó al menos 15 heridos